how to deal with difficult questions at
work so I got a great question front of
my YouTube viewers love you guys Jackie
who wrote in to say if you don't mind
maybe you can share on how do you deal
with difficult questions during work
will you get nervous when there's a
question you're unsure of the solutions
at that moment thank you sincerely from
the bottom of my heart
Jackie Jackie is a great question and
everybody at some point will get
questions that they have no idea what
the answer to and do you get nervous of
course you get nervous I don't know I
don't know anybody who doesn't get
nervous when they're put on the spot and
asked a question and they don't know the
answer to and that's okay it's okay to
be nervous I think what really makes a
difference is how you approach your
answer I honestly think that the best
answer is to be honest and if you don't
know the answer to it you say I honestly
don't know the answer to that question
but I'm gonna find out as soon as I can
and get back to you I would respect that
person way more than the person who
tries to flub an answer and stutter and
you know you they don't you know that
they don't know the answer and they're
just floundering around trying to hope
that the next minute passes without them
getting into more trouble right we have
pretty high BS meters people can tell
when you don't know what you're talking
about and you're trying to fake your way
through something right and so if
somebody does that to me I lose so much
respect for that person I'd rather you
come to me and say I honestly don't know
what the answer is but I'm going to find
out as soon as I can and get back to you
I respect that person then the trick is
after that to deliver right you got to
go and find the solution as quickly as
possible you're hustling you're
researching you're finding out how to
answer that question and you get back to
the person as soon as you can I was
thinking about how can I over deliver
like crazy on this so it's not just
getting back quickly it's giving them
exactly what they want and ideally a
little bit more so think about what else
they want other problems that might come
up afterwards and giving a little bit
more information to show that you've
really gone out and done your homework
I would then just follow it up with
showing that you care right showing that
you want to make this right showing that
this is important to you right so I
would even end with something like you
know I really want to make sure that
that we've answered all the problems
we've solved this completely I'm
available anytime here's my cellphone
number call me if it's midnight tonight
and you have a question call me because
I want to make sure that we get this
thing done and that you're really happy
right and they may not call you at
midnight and that's okay but it shows
that you care and you're gonna have
people then come in and say you know
what I want Jackie on my team I want to
work with Jackie right you're gonna get
promoted you're gonna get more
opportunities and you're building
relationships that will serve you for
the rest of your life
so that's what I would do believe for
those of you watching you like this
video you can watch more subscribe to
the channel you can support me by
clicking on the link in the description
and leave a comment let me know what you
think I love hearing from you guys ask
your question like a video response
thank you so much I'll see you soon